okay so this is my spoiler review of
Avengers endgame if you haven't seen the
movie yet and you do not want to be
spoiled at all
I would suggest watching my spoiler free
review first and then come back here
after you've seen the movie this is my
last warning about spoilers so if you
don't wanna be spoiled turn back now so
jumping into this movie I had really
high expectations like everybody else in
the world because especially I loved
infinity war now infinity war was one of
those movies that right from the start
it sucked you in and didn't let go and
it had a lot of unique things going on
and definitely felt like Empire Strikes
Back of star wars in the Marvel Universe
where thaw knows becomes like the Darth
Vader he's a great villain which was
much needed for Marvel and the problem
here is in an end game everything that
worked for infinity war they did the
opposite and that starts off with Thanos
Thanos made infinity war what it was it
had all these great Avengers but I think
what put the next level and caught
people off guard was how great honest
was now complicated villainy was
especially about what he was doing and
wiping out half the population but this
movie decides to not even go into that
and they as you see kill Thanos right in
the beginning and everyone was expecting
Thor to get his Redemption because he
didn't hit him in the head but they do
it in the first ten minutes in the movie
and that to me was a big choice they
took and I totally disagreed with it and
it ruined the rest of the movie for me
because what that did was all that
momentum they built in infinity war and
that character of Thanos they really set
up was just wiped out now you see foul
no snart's the movie but this is the old
earth honest before all this happening
so he's kind of just a shell of himself
and just confused at what's going on and
then he starts getting it but you don't
get the same fanos here you don't get
the speeches you don't get the
complications of them and it comes to
the last scene where he even says line
or he's like now I just want to destroy
everybody so he's just become
like any other boring villain that just
wants to take over the world and there's
nothing to it so the writers here
decided not even to go into what they
set up with that and that also goes into
with Gamora
Gamora dies in infinity war and then she
was basically just thrown in here as old
Gamora from before and then he gets
super confusing and then it's really
kind of lackluster when she runs into
star-lord here because he loves her he
just lost her but it's just as quick
scene and it's not a good payoff and you
don't even know she gets what the hell
is going on and they just that was a
huge letdown and instead of maybe having
Gamora have a Redemption arc and really
deal with how she would be brought back
to life instead of just using everything
under this time-travel cheat they just
decided to give this movie to nebula who
to me it's a sucky character I don't
think I people enjoy nebula she's
annoying she's just that broody sci-fi
character you've seen in a hundred
things before and that is a big problem
I head if you look at the time that
certain characters got in this movie
there's a poster people released of the
actual poster Avengers and they give
each person's amount of time in this
movie and what really shocked me was is
basically nebula had 45 minutes in this
movie as did Hawkeye where someone who's
on the poster a Koi she got six minutes
in the movie and that didn't make sense
to me cuz I thought what they set up so
well in infinity war was having each of
these newer characters lose someone
important and that they would have to
redeem just like rocket was trying to
get back his crew and basically they
have I thought a Koi was gonna be that
for black panther but I guess during
this movie she just was chilling in
Wakanda not doing anything and then she
just appears at the end that made no
sense and to have Hawkeye now become a
star of the show was frustrating because
hey no one's really crazy about Hawkeye
in general and I think what happened if
any war was he wasn't in it so sure he
was gonna get more time now but I don't
remember anyone being like man I missed
Hawkeye and if any war that would have
been way better with him
and I just think this whole Ronin thing
with him was kind of silly and it really
didn't go anywhere and to have even the
opening scene he gets in this movie
where his family disappears kind of felt
like they were over even doing disappear
shock where he was like whoa there goes
his family like you could see there
coming a mile away they already did this
with the end of ant-man the wasp and
honestly maybe this Hawkeye family
disappearing would have been a better
endgame scene for I mean better after
credit scene thrown in maybe for Captain
Marvel or even an offending or
mid-credits scene just showing oh this
is where Hawkeye has been he lost his
family you didn't need to put this in
this movie and problem this movie too is
three hours long and you think wow if
it's three hours must be great but no
it's actually just a bunch of deleted
type scenes here that were put in for
some reason I mean there's a chunk of
this movie in the middle that is really
not great and that really sums it up too
with the Hulk dabbing it kind of felt
like in last Jedi when Luke Skywalker
did his jzj off-the-shoulder I don't
know why this was even thrown in and the
Hulk was really not great in this movie
him coming to peace with himself was set
up in the last movie but they did it
really well where you were learning
about it as and went on and now they
just gave it to you and we didn't get to
see angry Hulk he didn't I mean if you
look at both of these movies he didn't
really do anything he didn't have a
moment he didn't have his big fighting
Hulk moment he wasn't the Hulk and that
goes to a big complaint on people had as
did I that Thor was the star of the show
besides Thanos in the Finney war and in
this he's just a chubby drunk and that
was problematic as well because he's
just stays that way the whole movie and
it's really disappointing because I feel
like Captain America and Iron Man got
their nice send-off so and Thor's was
just like oh I guess we're sticking with
him and he's gonna stay around for the
next Guardians movie and that scene too
was just annoying like him in star-lord
just fighting on this the the ship at
the end just bantering and overdoing
this Marvel humor to the point
was unbearable I mean and that was just
overkill in the movie as well where
there's so many heavy scenes going on
here and then they just have to throw a
joke in every single time where it's
just like just let something be and I
think Infinity Ward the perfect balance
of humor and seriousness or didn't get
too dark and it had jokes that worked
and a lot of jokes and this one misfired
it almost felt like this movie was
written by completely different people
and directed by different people as well
because again
- everything was just easy it was just
yet let's just use the quantum realm to
fix everything and it was kind of like
oh yeah all right they just used the
cop-out of everything's down to
time-travel and then it was just kind of
silly at the end when dr. strangers lets
everyone back in whoop-dee-doo you see
about a hundred people on the screen but
this again is what if Infinity Ward done
this it wouldn't have been as good
infinity war was able to pull it off
with all these characters in such a
magical way where everyone had their
moment every beat in the fight scene was
awesome and had a big thing everyone had
to do where this was just okay now all
these zombie dogs or whatever they are
running around these alien dogs and
they're fighting them and it's a way too
much CGI and I didn't feel any combat
here and if you're telling me that
Captain America getting Thor's Hammer's
the coolest thing you've ever seen it
still doesn't make a lot of sense and
it's really for the kids and that's cool
and all but it's too easy
it wasn't clever like infinity or
infinity Wars big reveals are all really
clever and every seen that movie counted
where you just have a stretcher that I'm
reflecting in this movie and it's really
boring and you see in the trailer so you
have something cool like rocket on war
machines back but they didn't really get
to fight together they separate all
these groups which got me really excited
when they're time traveling to different
places and they don't really do anything
and all we really get is Tony Stark and
Captain America basically in a Mission
Impossible movie but there's not that
feeling of wow I haven't seen this
before or this is really smart and
fooled me or just blew my mind in that
sense didn't and that battle was
disappointing to me I mean again the
battle starts we're waiting for it the
whole freaking movie two hours to get to
it and right when it starts they're
still just awkward moments where they to
characters just had to start talking in
the middle of the battle it just slows
everything down and they really you know
everyone's cut split on politics with
these type of things but if you're gonna
do a scene where all the female
superheroes line up which looked awesome
earn it and make it awesome or awesome
by us believing it and buying it in the
sense of Gamora again we didn't even
know what was going on with her and then
all of a sudden they're they know each
other and everything makes sense and
ready to fight together get there show
us more of Captain Marvel's character in
the movie they have no idea what to do
with her she was in the movie 15 minutes
and she comes in and out she's got the
Superman problem where she's too
powerful they don't know what to do with
her people thought the Russo brothers
would figure it out and they didn't
she's still just brooding around and
it's not like they have three hours here
they could have spent a couple minutes
with the Avengers reacting to who
Captain Marvel was and what she was
about I mean Tony Stark gets saved by
her and then he's like all right cool
it's like they're not going into like
why do you have this super-strength what
are you really doing and then there's a
chief with the script of yeah I'm gonna
go help out my other plants because they
got affected too I'll be back and then
she comes back at the end and she
doesn't do really anything final
destroys her but meanwhile she's able to
carry a ship down and save Tony so I
know I'm venting because I'm just
frustrated because so many people are
acting well this movie and it's making
me feel like everyone's just kind of
turning a blind eye to what's really
happened here because if you loved
infinity war how could you like this
movie it's complete opposite it did
everything wrong in my opinion and I did
like things about it look it's not as
bad as Captain Marvel it's not as bad as
ant-man in the wasp
it's has its moments I mean there and
there are jokes that land I think Paul
Rudd was still on point and I think him
with Tony Stark together had some really
good moments and I think there was
payoffs but I just don't think anything
was clever about it and fanos was
basically like he was non-existent it
was just him in the past now so I think
the time travel was just a trap and it's
ruined a lot of shows and movies before
and this was just another case of that
and it was a bad decision and they
didn't even used doctor strains time
stone to even do it they just
copped out with a quantum realm they
didn't even make it interesting with
Infinity stones so that was really
frustrating I think it worries me about
where this is going because again that
was the best part of the way to me I
will say it was Tony Stark's death
because it worked
everyone had it's here in the theater
yes but again you know that was gonna
happen something like that that was easy
and it was gonna be effective because of
how many movies had done before this no
matter what you did no matter how bad
and may have thought the move was before
it was gonna work and they knew that and
it did work but it's just like I'm
worried because if you're passing the
torch now to Spider Man and Captain
Marvel black panther black panther kind
of the role of Captain America is a
little more straightforward more plane
and personality but I feel like we're
missing someone in that Tony Stark vibe
of the total personality you don't know
what they're gonna do there's such a
variable mood swings all that that's not
really there because Captain Marvel also
is kind of just a straight brute and her
personality and spider-man's still a kid
- so he's got comic relief but we don't
have that kind of big ego they're going
on or personality and that that worries
me a bit maybe because Disney now has
the rights to 20 Century Fox maybe they
consider bringing someone like dead
pulling to fill that role who knows but
I was really disappointed and I just
hope you don't think I'm doing this to
have a different take than everybody
else I just think I felt like going
after like I feel crazy that wasn't that
great and say hey look everyone loves it
so they did something right but I just
feel like not everyone's being honest
with themselves so if you take your kind
of fanboy glasses off for a second and
realize wait a minute this isn't a great
movie and this is you sit back and kind
of know this is kind of stupid where if
any War I didn't feel that one bit so
disappointing
again I'm ripping on the movie but it's
still a Marvel movie it's still super
high-quality it still has its moments so
I'm still gonna give it about a 7.5
which is decent but for the expectations
I had it's nowhere near it if any Wars
way better I almost wish I just watched
infinity war never really saw this
because it's just a big letdown but
let me know he thought of and when you
see it down below I'd love to hear your
thoughts and I'm sure I pissed off a lot
of people but again everyone has a right
to an opinion I respect yours if you
love it I'd love to hear it we talked
about it and yeah so please subscribe to
my channel so you don't miss more of my
reviews and follow me at Steve rd1 on
Twitter Instagram for more of me and
I'll see you next time